no one is expecting a normal christmas
least of all those who've lost loved
ones to the pandemic
in london grieving relatives accused
boris johnson's government of
mishandling its response
and demanded a public inquiry this is my
father michael he died
eight months ago tomorrow we were hoping
that by now lessons would have been
learnt
they have not been learned test and
trace is not working that's very clear
mistakes keep
being made the government refuses to
admit to any mistakes
if one doesn't reflect on one's mistakes
how can they be corrected
there are concerns that the government
is about to bungle christmas as well
with warnings from the medical and
scientific communities about the deadly
consequences
of plans to relax restrictions so that
families can
meet they've provoked a change of advice
not a change of plan
a smaller christmas is going to be a
safer christmas
and a shorter christmas is a safer
christmas
when we say three households can meet on
five
days i want to stress that these are
maximums not targets
to aim for the uk is not heading into
the gloom
alone germany has gone into a stricter
lockdown after previous restrictions
failed to bring infection numbers down
on wednesday the country reported a
record number of coronavirus deaths
they call me this isn't normal it's very
strange it's not normal
i don't know what these politicians want
to do they've left it all open for too
long
and now all of a sudden we have to
quickly buy everything in two days
we don't know what they're doing anymore
in italy meanwhile they've been warnings
of a national tragedy after the
country's statistics bureau said that
deaths this year would be the highest
since
world war ii the government says it's
considering small adjustments to the
current restrictions
critics feel much more is required
many european countries are planning to
begin a vaccine rollout by the end of
december
pending approval by the european
medicines agency
light at the end of the tunnel but the
tunnel still has some way to go
jonah al jazeera